a sign of the times a mast governor of
New York arrives for the reopening of
the stock exchange trading floor nearly
two months after coronavirus shut it
down for the first time and it's more
than a hundred year history Andrew Cuomo
rang the opening bell to cheers from
traders also wearing masks only a
quarter have been allowed back the rest
continued to work remotely making for a
sparsely populated and unusually sedate
trading floor traders were forbidden
from using public transport to get to
work and also needed to take a
temperature test
upon entering the building I feel very
safe and very comfortable coming back
into this building the measures that
they put in place prior to the NYC
closing and continuing through today is
something that's certainly reassuring
they were also required to sign a waiver
promising not to sue should they catch
coronavirus while at work necessary move
according to the stock exchange
president most of the people that work
down here on the trading floor are not
employees of the New York Stock Exchange
so we need to make sure that they're
committed to following all those
protection protective measures that we
put in place and the waiver is really
focused primarily on that as a governor
left
he seemed upbeat and pleased even as the
rest of New York City remains mostly
closed trading on the New York Stock
Exchange did not stop over the last two
months as the majority of buying and
selling is done electronically
however the reopening is significant
symbolism as the American economy inches
towards reopening Gabe rose Ando al
Jazeera New York